problem here well that is the issue
frankly
is that is one thing to say right go
back and carry on talking they've been
talking for literally
months and months now and there has been
precious little progress in three areas
those
areas are about what's called the level
playing field these are competition
rules designed to ensure
that companies for one of a better
expression companies in one country
don't get a
march on companies in another through
things like state aid or by differences
on
on workers rights that's one thing
another one is governance
in other words if there is a problem
with this agreement how
is that resolved and a third very
symbolic if not economically important
is fishing and that one has been pretty
intractable because it is seen as so
symbolically important for governments
in the united kingdom and also
specifically
in france but also in the netherlands
and belgium
and other countries and frankly unless
there is some
new mechanism which is going to unpick
these it is quite hard to see
how progress is going to be made simply
uh by ursula fonda line and boris
johnson saying go on go away and have
another couple of
days of trying to find a deal it's
possible but let's be honest they've had
months and gone
pretty much nowhere what i suspect is
going to happen is is that there are
going to have to be further negotiations
behind the scenes
there is going to have to be more
instructions certainly from the european
side to michelle barnier about what
compromises
he can make i imagine the same with with
boris johnson and lord frost
his negotiator i understand that both
michelle barnier and lord frost were
sitting
in the rooms listening in on those phone
calls
that is what is going to happen now i'm
hearing that these talks will reconvene
here in brussels and i would say that
that actually a senior eu diplomat said
to me earlier
that he thought that there was a bit of
theatrics going on that it needed
a whack but his prediction was that you
could have a couple of days of talks
that focus would be increased because of
the looming debate around the internal
market bill
in the uk and and he thought that it was
possible that a deal
could be done by monday evening
interesting that that is when ursula
fonda line and boris johnson have said
that they will
talk again frankly there is going to
have to be something going on behind the
scenes
just putting these negotiators back
together and asking them to try again
i don't think will work sure okay adam
well let's bring in joe pike in
westminster given what adam's saying
there joe
do you think that we have reason to be
pessimistic that a deal can be reached
i think there the this uh statement
leaves us feeling maybe a bit more
optimistic than we certainly started the
day
isabel because of course we knew that
this call was significant and would
probably steer us
towards the eventual conclusion that
certainly doesn't seem to be no deal
at this stage interesting that this
talks are starting so
uh fast again they will start tomorrow
but that
both leaders boris johnson anderson on
the line will talk on monday so i
suppose
the negotiators are being given a day a
day and a half to see if they can make
any progress perhaps
based on that private conversation today
between their uh two bosses or
the leaders will get involved yet again
certainly downing street were very
optimistic
uh towards the end of this week but uh
yesterday things changed they believe
that uh new demands were placed on them
by
uh michelle barnier new demands that
they think were coordinated by
france by spain perhaps by italy as well
and new demands not just on fishing but
on
estate a they were pretty frustrated
about that and
uh some in government think there is
absolutely no chance that they will
commit to any of the demands of course
david frost as
adam said there is with boris johnson at
checkers that's where
uh the prime minister took that call and
i'm sure they'll be discussing now
where to go next certainly conservative
mps seems to be
a pretty supportive of boris johnson in
private and in public i think in
contrast
it's ursula von de line who after uh
many months of saying that
the eu would speak as one now has the
far more difficult task
of trying to keep eu leaders focused
and trying to get them to commit to a
deal okay joe pike and westminster adam
parsons in brussels thank you both very
much
indeed for that just if you are tuning
in to reiterate what that statement said
uh ursher vonderlein and boris johnson
issuing
a joint statement saying that those
talks that talk on
a phone call for an hour this evening
was unable to break the deadlock that
they
uh remain to have significant
differences on those three critical
issues the level playing field
governance and fisheries
and they believe that their negotiating
team should resume talks tomorrow
in brussels and then that boris johnson
and ursula vanderlian should take
another phone call on monday evening
so what is at stake in these trade
negotiations and what would be the
implications for british business
if the uk were to leave the european
union without a deal at the end of the
year
becky johnson's been looking into it as
a nation we're about to find out what
brexit
really means a deal with the eu or no
deal
for so many so much is at stake
get away get away charlie beatty's
family have farmed here in warwickshire
for over six decades
come by missy come by 80
of the lamb produced on this farm goes
to an abattoir that exports the majority
to the eu
the fear if tariffs are imposed is
demand will fall
and so will the price of british lamb it
is a concern
definite absolutely yes it's a huge
concern there's too much of a hit to the
land markets
and then beef and arable beef and crops
for us as well
if if all three of those enterprises
take a hit there's no telling that we
could carry on as farmers
and they're not the only farmers afraid
their business simply won't survive
brexit the national farmers union warns
no deal would be catastrophic for
british farming
and says securing a deal is critically
important in order to avoid
significant disruption to british food
and farming
from land to sea the impact of tariffs
on exports to the eu
would be felt but the debate over
fishing rights is one of the major
sticking points preventing a deal
the eu still wants its fleets to have
access to british waters
if no deal is done they won't get that
pleasing
some in the british fishing industry but
for sectors that have
complex supply chains stretching across
the eu
no deal could be disastrous mass car
manufacturing in britain
already slowed by uncertainty around
brexit
could be forced to stop if there's no
trade deal that could be really quite
devastating for the industry
10 tariffs on exports would have a big
impact on production here and
jobs and potentially lots of plant
closures
to the point where even i think that the
mass car industry would struggle to
survive in the uk
as the deadline looms we will soon
finally know
what brexit means and the impact it will
have
on all our lives becky johnson sky news
well there will be plenty to discuss on
sophie ridge on sunday tomorrow when
she's joined by the former prime
minister gordon brown
also the environment minister george
eustis the shadow home secretary nick
thomas simons
the football star turned campaigner gary
neville as well as
saffron cordery from nhs providers
now gp surgeries in england have been
told to prepare to start staffing
covert 19 vaccination centers by the
14th of december
a letter sent to all surgeries and
primary care leads from nhs england and
nhs improvement
says it'll be one of the greatest
challenges the nhs has ever faced
but there's a warning today from the
uk's chief medical officers that the
vaccine will only have a marginal impact
on hospital numbers this winter
hender brady reports tell me your date
of birth across the country
flu jab season is well underway here at
this practice in harrow in northwest
london
dr david lloyd knows that very soon the
top priority
will be implementing the covert 19
vaccination program
well obviously a little nervous and also
a little excited we've
over the last few weeks there has been
in intense
work behind the scenes by uh by the
department of health to try and get it
all set up
uh we hope we've got a system that works
we've all
lots of us have volunteered to work in
the clinics outside of our normal hours
so we've got a lot of
clinicians and managers ready and
willing to give it
dr lloyd believes local gps and the
strength of their community ties will be
key
to getting a high uptake of the vaccine
with this particular pandemic
and this particular illness we are
dealing with
a huge amount of negative
internet publicity about vaccines in
general
and we've really got to try and overcome
this this vaccine is safe
it's effective and is going to get this
world
back to normal the first people to
receive the job will be those aged 80
and over
gene finney turns 89 on tuesday and
can't wait
to see life return to normal well i
would have it done
because actually you've got to have some
thing otherwise it might be a bit better
than
me having to stay in most of the time
i've very rarely come out shopping
i'm out today because i wanted some
fruit but normally i would be indoors
and my son does most of my shopping for
me
lydia o'connor's 93 year old father
hasn't been outside
since february being stuck indoors is
not the way forward for him but because
of the
the fear of catching the kovic or
spreading or whatever
he's like he's gone over the top with
protecting himself from people and
things
this conference venue in harrow will be
at the heart of getting this part of
north west london vaccinated
well this centre would normally be used
for wedding receptions
parties and seminars it's big it's
easily accessible and there's plenty of
room inside for a fridge
to store that vaccine in this primary
care network
the aim is to get seventy thousand
people vaccinated in the first three
months
dr lloyd and his colleagues have
volunteered to work extra
to make sure that target is hit and the
brady sky news
in harrow meanwhile rush has already
begun rolling out
its vaccine the sputnik v president
putin has ordered officials to
prioritize vaccinating doctors teachers
and social workers dana magnay reports
from moscow
this is russia's answer to covid19
sputnik v
the first vaccine to be registered
globally and now the first licensed
vaccine to be rolled out for wider
distribution
this woman says it was quick and
pain-free
it's just moscow for now and just medics
teachers and social workers
dmitry bury works in a bank and he
wanted the jab
he's disappointed when he's turned away
why were you in such a rush to get the
vaccine
you're young and healthy
mass vaccination needs a massive scaling
up of production
it won't be till next year that russia
can roll sputnik v
out across the country and there are
nine other vaccines in the pipeline too
there's hardly a rush to get this
vaccine there are 70 poly clinics like
this one
across the russian capital where you can
sign up register
and then get the first of your two doses
of sputnik v
but today only 17 people signed up for
this particular clinic
patient light journalist heavy russia
has already vaccinated 60 000 people
from at-risk groups beyond the phase 3
trials
so today's pr moment looked a little
like an attempt to score another first
but with a record 28 000 cases across
russia in the last 24 hours
it's definitely needed
for
with all the major global vaccines
claiming a more than 90
success rate he is hoping that she's
right
diana magnay sky news moscow
[Applause]
some breaking news and we've just
received this picture of the prime
minister boris johnson
during his phone call with president of
the european commission of ursula
vondelaine the call
was taken by him at checkers his country
residents
we understand that sir david frost is
in checkers with the prime minister over
the course of the weekend and
during that phone call it was agreed
that given that there were still
significant differences on those three
critical issues we've all become so
familiar with the level playing field
governance
and fisheries they felt it was
worthwhile for another day of
negotiating in brussels tomorrow ahead
of a
second call on monday evening we are
expecting to get
a translation of ursula fondling
statement for you
shortly and we'll bring you that just as
soon as we do now donald trump is
returning to the campaign trail this
evening in support of two republicans
who face january runoffs which will
ultimately decide the control of the u.s
senate
the outcome in the state of georgia will
be crucial to the balance of power in
washington
so speak to our foreign affairs editor
debra haynes who's in georgia for us
lots of supporters out for president
trump today
yes i'm in the city of valdosta in
georgia
right on the florida border and this is
where donald trump will be making his
first appearance for a rally
since the election an election that joe
biden
has won and yet president trump is is
refusing to concede
claiming that there's been widespread
fraud and the election has been stolen
and so
focus will really be on whether he
chooses to use this rally
to rally his base to come out and
support the two senators that are going
to be running
for this key election this run-off
election
next month to see who controls the
senate or whether he's going to be
more focused on his political future
as you mentioned there are supporters
out here in force already it's six hours
until
he's due to come and speak and these
supporters have no doubt
that they want their president to remain
the president
for another four years and they are
convinced that this election
has been stolen and i've actually got a
couple of supporters here
keith and steve have agreed to talk to
us and um steve is holding a sign you
can see
stop the steal and what does that mean
well
what stopped the steel is a rejection of
this fraudulent election
it's a it's a rejection to stop the of
not only our vote
but our voice our freedoms and our
country
and we want to remind those that we can
do this
we're here to support donald trump and
also to remind
purdue and loughler that they need to
have president trump's back
and not be a rhino republican in name
only and have his back too
so we expect them to fully support
donald trump in his call
for election integrity so david perdue
and kelly loffler are the two senators
who are running for the republican
ticket in this senate election
but you think the election the the
election for the president was
fraudulent they're
are you going to bother voting i i live
in the state of georgia
i voted for senator perdue the first
time laughler was off
obviously appointed by governor kemp so
i'm not saying i'm not going to vote for
purdue and lafleur but they need to make
it easier
they're making it really really hard
right now
for president trump's supporters so
we're asking for something
for our vote we're not asking for free
college
we're not asking for for anything like
the democrats do
all i want is i want them to show
support for president trump
and the way they so the specific way
they show support
for president trump is they put pressure
on governor kemp
to ask for them to certify all the
signatures
on the votes we also want them to do a
forensic
audit on all of the dominion voting
systems and there's one other thing
why would we go out and vote in this
runoff election
with the same exact system that produced
the fraud the first time
we don't want to use dominion voting
systems this time we want to use paper
ballots
i think that we should have video
cameras at every polling place
so we can see the fraud and get it
captured on tape if it happens again
all these claims of fraud though they've
yet to be properly substantiated and
a lot of these um these legal challenges
have been thrown out it does seem like
president-elect biden is going to be the
next president of the united states
what do you think about that well first
of all the media does not declare the
winner and we have traveled the country
in many cities atlanta dc chicago
lansing phoenix
and the evidence has been presented in a
lot of these legislative
committee hearings and there's an
incredible amount of evidence
in fact the kind of evidence that's
committed in court in fact i think it's
overwhelming
that the fraud is just just clear-cut
will you accept a president biden
um he'll never be my president right so
i want to accept president biden i'm
going to stand
and i'm going to use my first amendment
right and i am going to protest
and i am going to keep america the
shining city on the hill
i'm not going to let them take our
liberties so we have the first amendment
in this country
and i'm not i'm not going to let this
let this go globally
it's very clear that the supporters here
are not backing down
on this election yet they still want to
see president trump here for another
four more
years okay thank you very much deborah
just want to bring you a breaking line
that we're hearing on this developing
story this evening on those brexit talks
we're hearing from the irish
prime minister welcoming the resumption
of those talks in brussels tomorrow
which was the outcome of that call
between airship underlying
and prime minister boris johnson we're
told that the irish prime minister said
that the agreement
is in everyone's interest we're keeping
a close eye on those developments for
you but in the meantime do stay with us
here on sky news after the break we'll
have
an interesting story as the raf tracks
the world's largest
iceberg as it heads towards the island
of south georgia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers welcome to
divided states
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to the
safety ridge podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the world's biggest iceberg
has been photographed drifting through
the south atlantic
the iceberg known as a68a
was captured by an raf crew as it heads
towards the british outpost of south
georgia potentially
putting the island's ecosystem at risk
sky's hanisha sethi reports
this is the world's largest iceberg
at 93 miles long and 30 miles wide
is drifting along the southern atlantic
ocean but
this poses a potential danger it's
heading towards the british overseas
territory of south georgia
where if it gets stuck in shallow
coastal waters
it could cause ecological problems and
shipping hazards
it means that the penguins and the seals
have to go
further to find food they have to do a
big detour
around around this big mass of ice to
find
food and if they have to go too far they
can't get back to their chicks in time
and what we saw in 2004 when iceberg
a34 grounded around south georgia
was countless numbers of dead penguin
chicks and abandoned nests
the iceberg has been meandering since it
broke off from antarctica's ice shelf in
2017
and scientists believe this is in
response to the earth's warming climate
this imagery captured by the raf shows
the edges of the iceberg
melting and crumbling and was taken to
assess any change
once they got in the in the vicinity of
the of the iceberg it's very easy to
spot
so much so that when they tried to
position the aircraft to image the whole
iceberg
in in one image they were unable to do
it and and some of the images actually
prove that
it is such a huge iceberg
there's hope the iceberg could
eventually loop around south georgia
or break apart and avoid any harm
but the images will be analyzed to
understand just how the iceberg will
behave in the coming weeks
with a close eye kept on its movements
initial sethi sky news
well more on that developing story this
evening in the last few moments we've
heard from the european union's chief
negotiator michelle barnier he says that
we will see if there is a way forward as
work
continues tomorrow that's being reported
to us from
reuters um we are yet to hear anything
from lord frost but we understand he is
at checkers
with the prime minister ahead of
traveling back to brussels tomorrow
to meet with michelle barnier to
continue those negotiations in hope
of a resolution before monday evening
keeping a close eye on those
developments lots of lines coming
through for you this evening we will
bring you them all
as soon as we get them but in the
meantime stay with us coming up after
the break we can have some sport for you
action from the premier league as
football stadiums reopen
to some fans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
for me
now you come to the plastic graveyard
it's a
disgrace for mankind i think that you
find this in animals
the plastic we discard ends up on our
plate
it's entering our body
[Music]
so the beach is just here just behind
his house
[Music]
we're asleep walking into an
environmental catastrophe
the ocean where life on earth began is
being turned
into a synthetic soup and to understand
why
there is no better place to come than
mumbai for
for indians it's like every dirt must go
into the waterways
now the exact problem of plastic in
ocean is this now you come to the
plastic graveyard here in the ocean the
plastic graveyard there is plastic
everywhere
the whole beach is just strewn with
plastic
this isn't litter dropped on the beach
it's come from the sea
twice a day the tide brings in yet more
this is devastation thomas have you seen
so much plastic at a beach i've never
seen so much gas to get a beach
this isn't a beach horrendous horrendous
this is a rubbish dump not a beach
worldwide we're dumping the equivalent
of one rubbish truck of trash
into the water every minute by 2050 the
plastic in the sea
could weigh more than all the fish
it's actually quite upsetting to see so
much
plastic on a beautiful beach i'm
mentally disturbed every time i come
here you know because
it's cleaning
but we are not going to give up thomas
this will continue this war is going to
continue
he started the world's biggest beach
clean with 4
000 tons of trash cleared in just one
year
for his zeal the united nations made him
an environmental champion
so the ocean throws it up ocean pukes
out every two months three months you
know
and if you don't clean it it will get
piled on piled on piled on
but the sand seems to take it in i think
you know single-use plastic
has no place in 21st century i'm of a
very firm believer
it has no place in this world
and it's so convenient of course it may
be convenient for some but
it's just not convenient for the fishes
and the marine creatures and marine
birds you know it's their house it's
it's there where they belong they live
they survive
they're crying for justice because we
have messed up to their houses
and i don't take it kindly no species
have a right to destroy somebody else's
house
[Music]
hi praveen how are you
[Music]
there used to be plenty of life in these
waters
now the fishing boats lie idle
if we put a net we'll get just a lot of
plastic
and all the waste products which are
flowing in the tricks so this is my
point fishing here no point fishing here
because uh
uh all the net will be filled with the
plastic only that's why
and this is in your lifetime that you've
seen that change yeah yeah because when
we were scared
we had we used to see a lot of fishing
in the creek only but
now as we grow in last 20 30 years we
have seen the
all the fish has gone only the pollution
i have not come here for sainthood i
have come here to clean because i feel
there is a need in me
and if it becomes everybody's need you
know
things will be sorted out
it's this rapid adaptability together
with the attractiveness usefulness
and low cost of the plastic itself that
has made this industry one of the
fastest growing in the nation's history
the future of plastics is bright indeed
[Music]
we use 320 million tons of plastic
every year it's cheap light and durable
you can freeze it stack it
any which way used in everything from
cotton bud sticks to spacecraft
liftoff all we need is this burner this
flask
and this reflux condenser just a moment
please
four percent of world oil production is
used as a raw ingredient
chemicals are added but they can be
toxic and just
five percent is effectively recycled
mechanical and he grows up
welcome on board thank you very much
let's go and find some microplastics
so we've got a manta net in the water
you can see there's these fins
spread out to the side i mean a little
bit like the
edge of a manta ray if you like it's
helping to keep the
the net buoyant at the water surface
which is where
we'd expect to find a lot of plastics
with this particular approach what we're
really looking for is a small
piece as the the microplastics anything
less than five millimeters in size so
that's not
microscopic you could see them to the
naked eye we're trawling for those tiny
pieces
fragments of everyday items broken down
by
sunlight and the churning waves over
many years
they are a menace in the ocean you could
take you know
a large plastic bottle you might be
familiar with that might break down into
millions of small pieces of plastic
it's quite difficult to put a a robust
quantity
but where is this there are a few marine
creatures that would eat an entire
bottle
exactly if you've got a bottle breaking
down into millions of pieces that's
millions of opportunities for a small
fish to consume it
that's right well it opens up the
potential for ingestion to a much wider
diversity of organism
so we've got quite a bit of debris in
there
what we really need is to pick through
this carefully in the lab i'll put or
transfer them to the jar but you can see
that we have got
bits of plastic on some of these leaves
plastic takes decades perhaps even
centuries to disintegrate into tiny
pieces
but it never completely disappears
we've got the sample that we got in the
manta net this morning
um what i want to do is see if we can go
through
it and pull out any pieces that look a
little bit like plastic well we see
a range of different common polymers you
know polyethylene polypropylene
polystyrene to identify exactly what
these are we need a more detailed
forensic
analysis we find just a handful of
pieces
in our 15-minute trawl but it's still
hugely significant
what we're finding is on average one or
two pieces of plastic per cubic meter of
sea water
so you know it's not an island of debris
that we're talking about here
but if you scale that up and you think
about how many cubic meters of
water there are in plymouth sound around
the coast of the uk
around the world suddenly you realize
that we're talking about
millions actually trillions of pieces of
plastic of this
size that are now floating around the
surface of the sea waters around
around the globe
the beaches are wild the sea birds
abundant
and the goals themselves they're just
resting here yes
yeah do you get large flocks of them
yeah especially when fishing fleet comes
in all of them occasionally have plastic
in their stomach
but the one that has it regularly is the
former
a little bit they probably get through
the fish they eat that has eaten
plastics from deeper water layers
but most of it is from the surface most
of it is floating plastic
when dead foamers wash ashore their
stomachs are examined the birds give
scientists a chance to gauge
just how much plastic is out in the open
ocean
the postmortem isn't for the squeamish
this bird has died slowly
it's there's no fat remaining
so a healthy foamer you would not see
these feather pins stick out it would be
a
smooth layer of fat so it just burnt up
all the fat that it has while it's done
once you've eaten too much of this
muscle proteins
you're gone so that looks a heavy
stomach
there's quite a bit of stuff in here i'm
not sure what it is but
we'll see
so you can see there's a lot of plastic
in here okay
yeah so this gizzard is basically full
of plastic
and what would the consequences have
been there for the bird well if the
stomach is full
it gives a false sense of satiation
so it just doesn't hungry it doesn't eat
as much so could that have been
why and this this bird is clearly
starved yes
yeah that could be a contributing factor
yes yes certainly
so what does that tell you about the
life of that bird
well it's it's suffering from our
mistakes
and it's
it's a disgrace from mankind i think too
that you find this in animals
all belgians um really look forward
towards
what we call the mussel season which
starts like officially in the beginning
of july
it's like a big event that the
you know the muscles are there and then
you know throughout summer
and uh early autumn belgians eat muscles
great here we go thank you very much
so colin is this a a very belgian
preparation of muscles
it is indeed it's the the simplest one
and
and to me the most tasty of swan it's uh
just the mussels with added onion and
celery
let's put it in the in in the pot and
it's cooked for five minutes
and that's what you get a mussel filter
is about 20 to 25 liters of water
per day so there's a lot of
water coming in that water contains
micro
plastics this portion of microsoft
contains about
90 particles of plastic we've estimated
that
uh a belgium would
eat anything between 2 000 and 11 000
micro
particles per year 11 000 yes
our children will be eating even more as
plastics accumulate in the ocean
by the end of the century europeans are
likely to be consuming as many as
three quarters of a million pieces of
plastic
every year we've developed a technique
which
dissolves all the the tissue and
what we're left with is in fact any
microplastic which would be in the
tissue
keep on looking if we see something
suspicious
yeah yeah it's pink color and it's a
rectangular shape
based on what we've seen before this
surely is a
detailed ct scans of living muscles have
shown the pieces
aren't just in the stomach they're
actually in the body tissue
there's some really hard evidence like
what you buy in the shop there will be
some plastic in there
[Music]
the first risk assessments in the lab
show microplastics can cross from our
stomachs
to our bloodstream just a few dozen
particles a year for now
but by the end of the century it could
be thousand
pieces accumulating year after year
i've asked many physicians colleagues
professors and and so on
what does microplastic what could
microplastic do when it gets into our
blood system
and the blunt answer was we don't know
[Music]
so i mean i'm not worried about my
lifetime anymore about plastics
but perhaps uh the next generation or
two generations further on
might say you know they left us a rotten
plastic legacy
[Music]
[Music]
we found plastic that's been
tucked into corals
we found plastic that's tucked into
rock crevices and all of this sort of
suffocates the animals that are
around there um they think it's food
sometimes
and they try and eat it which obviously
they can't digest
and then there's a plastic that floats
mid water that doesn't really settle
down until it reaches the shop
and if it happens to be a plastic bag it
sort of
resembles a jellyfish which are turtle
food
so turtles could engulf it
[Music]
plastic bags are banned on these indian
islands but they're still
at the mercy of the ocean currents the
waste that comes in through the currents
comes in
from southeast asia so countries like
indonesia
thailand singapore malaysia
and it's a lot of footwear a lot of
bottles so
plastic bottles things that float easily
and
all of it is brought in by the current
but some plastic travels much further
accumulating in huge circulating masses
of water
in the north and the south atlantic the
north and the south pacific
and the indian ocean these are the five
great gyres it's all linked it's all
one ocean
even in the uk remote communities are
being affected
and actually it's not too bad today this
is a good day
i've seen it over the wall that depth
so it's and that's a good couple of
meters
easily all the time
it's getting caught in little nooks and
crannies all down the log
and then when you get a surge of a
tidewater you know a high tide
it comes out and lands here
mary was born in the village and never
left it was a childhood paradise
not anymore plastic wasn't a thing that
we ever had you know there was never any
plastic and there was never an
interference when we're swimming or
jumping into the lock and hitting a
plastic bottle
so there was nothing like that and the
shore was clean
that's not our rubbish that's came from
somewhere else
it's nice when you've been out in in the
wilds to come back to
the comfort of a good scottish bnb
exactly and smell the fresh bread and
the nice
marmalade yeah christina moved here two
years ago to open a bmb
so this is our one of our premier rooms
and it's a stunning view
if you can look beyond the plastic on
the shore i've had actually quite a few
people asking me why is the community so
filthy
why why do you have a landfill out there
so is the assumption
by outsiders that this is rubbish that's
come from the village
from us yeah yeah because they don't
understand tourists are beginning to go
elsewhere
the effect on the community can't be
underestimated
they've tried to deal with it on their
own they've done whatever they possibly
can
it hasn't worked it's still happening
and they're tired
and that is being reflected in the
amount of places that are for sale here
now the businesses that are closing
this community is giving up and they've
been left to deal with this on their own
for so long
that they do say it's it's it's a
thankless task we can't do anything
about it
but in in the face of of the plastic
tied
do you not feel overwhelmed um i'm
incredibly overwhelmed
um i may not have been born here and
lived my life here but i'm going to live
the rest of my life here so this is a
complete total life investment for me
and cleaning up the lock is actually
part of your mission
completely one of my missions yes
you've been doing this for 61 weeks now
yeah this is 62 weeks now 62 weeks yeah
and there's still rubbish here yeah but
you see the difference do you oh my god
it's a huge difference
the white sand is visible which was
never there this is what is what i do we
call it maintenance now
once you've done this beach where will
you go next we go to the next beach
there are 19 beaches and when we go to
the next beach it's the locals who have
to stand up
i'm just going to provoke them like i
provoked all my volunteers i promote
them on and off on and off
and then they come automatically known
it's my ocean my beach my love for it
you know
do you think that day will come very
soon very soon very soon with the action
of so many people
one day you can swim again
the next generation the young generation
here to see your t-shirt
save the beach save the people yeah yeah
maybe one day you'll be able to play
cricket on the beach
that'd be nice with no rubbish no
plastic
yeah i don't put a bit on the beach
you don't put a bid on the beach you
just clean up everybody else's mess
that's great well good luck to you young
man one day you can sit back and enjoy
it
we are 1.5 billion indians imagine three
billion hands picking it up how many
pieces of plastic can it be
[Music]
it may take a generation before
we are used to not throwing plastic away
but i think by telling the story it's a
problem
gradually it will take effect
the only way to stop the plastic tide is
to
to manage it in a better way
[Music]
i believe we can have and we can use
plastics to our advantage
without the need for this accumulation
of waste and that's what brings me hope
[Music]
really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is sky news at seven our top
stories progress made
brexit talks to continue tomorrow after
a phone call between the prime minister
and the european commission president
as they attempt to break the deadlock a
joint statement says the two sides are
stuck on three critical issues we'll
look at the impacts on industries
in the uk britain gets ready for the
covert jab the first vaccination taking
place on
tuesday they're already underway in
russia
after moscow rolls out the sputnik v in
hospital
the world's biggest iceberg captured on
film drifting through the atlantic
and in sport fans returned to the
premier league as west ham play mouse
united
in the first top flight fixture with a
crowd in almost nine months
good evening the prime minister and
european commission president ursula van
der lion have spoken on the phone this
evening in an attempt to break the
brexit deadline
well in the last hour the two sides
released a joint statement which said
progress has been made
but significant differences still remain
in a moment we'll speak to our europe
correspondent adam parsons in brussels
but first ali fortescue is
in westminster for us ali it feels like
we've been here before
similar kind of issues still on the